PROFESSOR: This is [? Doctor ?]
MATLAB, Lecture 6, debugging.
We will use the function
Fibbo2 to demonstrate
some basic debugging.
The first thing you want
to do when you debug
is set a breakpoint at
an interesting line.
We'll set it at the very
first interesting line
of the function.
Since Fibbo2 is not in the
current folder nor in the path,
MATLAB pops up this
download box and asks us
whether we should add it to the
path or simply change folder.
We're going to change folder.
So now that we've
changed folder,
MATLAB was willing
to put a breakpoint.
And now if we run
Fibbo2 with 3, we
will get stopped right
here with the green arrow
on the breakpoint.
Notice that at this
point, n is defined
to be 3 because that was
the input we get gave Fibbo.
F is still not defined, and
v is not defined either.
After we do this one
line, F will be defined.
How do we do this one line?
We have to either click on
Step, or Step In, or Step Out,
or Continue.
All these things are
slightly different.
I'm going to use
Step, in this case.
So Step means to do this line
and step to the next line.
So now it did that and
F has been initialized.
Let's see-- yes, F is 1 1.
Here is the helper.
The helper is the
function that actually
does most of the calculation.
If we step over this one,
as well, we're almost done.
Now F is already
the full 3 vector,
and we will accept
the last term,
Fn, and put it
into v. Let's Step,
and now we're about to end.
Before we end, we can
check that v is 2.
So 2 is the value
that's going to be
returned in the next step.
We can Step again,
and now this arrow out
means that we're about to
leave the function when
doing nothing else.
And if we take one
more Step, we're out.
The answer is 2, and we're not
in the debugging mode anymore.
We never seem to
have entered helper.
And the reason for that was
that we stepped over this line
rather than stepping into it.
Let's do that again.
I'll move the breakpoint
and put it here.
And now I'll run it.
I can't run the function by
pressing this green arrow
because I'm not giving it
any input when I just run it.
If I run it, I'll get an error.
Now n is not defined.
And if I step over
right now, here's
my error-- not enough
input arguments
because n was not defined.
OK, so let's not
run it this way.
Let's run it this way,
but this time I'll
give it 5 as an input.
OK, so I put my breakpoint here.
I'm stopped right here.
And now I'm going
to not step over--
Step means step over.
I'll Step Into.
So Step Into means to step
into this function call.
So now we're inside
the function helper.
Notice that this green arrow
tells us where we came from--
sorry, this non-green arrow
tells us where we came from.
And this green arrow tells
us where we currently are.
We can see all of
these in the stack.
Here's the base.
This is where we
called Fibbo2 here.
Here's Fibbo2-- that's what
this non-green arrow is.
And here's Fibbo2/helper,
that's this location right here.
We can switch to
whatever we want.
So we can switch to the base.
Now we're not here and not here.
We're actually on the base.
And we can see who the
variables are here.
There are not that
many variables.
Specifically, n
is not a variable,
and v is not a variable,
and F is not a variable
when we're out here.
Let's go back to Fibbo2/helper.
So this F, of course,
is not going to be true.
Step Over this and now it's
going to kill helper again.
Let's go once in, just
to see how this looks.
So if we go in, now
the stack is becoming
more and more complicated.
There are two entries of
Fibbo2/helper because helper
called helper again.
n at this point is 4.
So in fact, it's
probably going to call it
one more time because the number
of elements in F is still 2.
We have to wait until
we reach down to 2.
So even if we Step
In again here,
now we're in helper three times.
Take a look-- where's my stack?
At this point, n is still 3.
It will happen once more.
And now it's going to all
start collapsing back.
So now I've called n with 3.
Now I'm starting to
come back out of it.
So F is going to start growing.
So helper has been
called, n is 3.
So now I'm going to put
F3 equals F2 plus F1.
Now this is a little bit boring.
So I can use Step Out to
step out of a function call.
So this basically runs until
the current element of stack
goes out.
It will return.
So if I Step Out once, I'll
have two functions-- well,
four functions left--
twice helper and then
Fibbo2 and base.
So Step Out-- let's
look at the stack again.
Let's Step Out again.
Let's look at the stack again--
good.
At this point, F is growing
and n is increasing.
And each time, I'm filling
up the relevant F. So now
I'm going to fill up F5--
Step, return.
Now I'm done with this function.
And I'm exiting the function,
so now I'm done here.
Now all the data is done.
I can Step.
And if you're bored
with this, you just
want to finish the function,
you can just call Continue.
And it will run through
the rest of the lines
unless it hits a breakpoint.
Now let's do this again.
While I'm here--
now I'm here again.
I'm in the command line.
I'm inside this function.
I can evaluate all
kinds of stuff.
I can look at F. I can
look at F1 plus F2.
I can evaluate all kinds of
things and even change things.
I can do silly stuff
like F1 equals 3.
And now F will be
starting with 3 and 1.
In the Fibonacci
sequence, the results
will be a very odd one, indeed.
Let's see how this works.
I'm going to put a breakpoint
here, press continue--
oh, because I ran it.
Let me call Fibbo5,
now change this to 3,
and now press Continue.
OK, so now what is F?
F is a Fibonacci sequence but
it's not the Fibonacci sequence
because it starts with 3 1.
And then there a 4, which
is the sum of 3 and 1;
and then a 5, which is 4 and 1;
and then a 9, which is 4 and 5,
et cetera.
I changed my Fibonacci
sequence while it was running.
And then that
changed, of course,
the rest of the operation.
There's another
type of breakpoint
that you can do that's called
a conditional breakpoint.
So let's do this one.
You notice that we had to wait
until we knew that n was 2.
We had to go Step In,
Step In again and again.
This can get boring.
So what we can do,
if you right click,
you can set a
conditional breakpoint.
So I want to stop
it on this line only
if, let's say n equals 3.
So now let me exit debug mode.
I'm going to call Fibbo
with 15, for example.
First it stops here.
I'll tell it to Continue.
And now it stops here.
Now notice this is
when n equals 3.
We started with n equals 15.
So that means that our
stack should be huge.
Indeed, our stack is huge.
We have Fibbo2 calling
the helper, which
calls the helper,
and the helper,
and the helper-- all these
call the helper again,
and again, and again
until n goes down to 3.
Now it's going to start
popping back up again.
All this time F hasn't been
changed because this line has
never been reached.
But now it has reached
for the first time.
And if I click Continue, it
won't stop at this breakpoint
again.
It only stops there
once when n is 3.
And now it ends.
Now it knows we're ready,
that v is whatever it is--
610.
And it's done.
One more Step--
it's almost done.
One more Step,
Continue-- and it's done.
610 is the answer.
And this is how you
can use the debugger.